hundreds of supporters greeted former
president James bolsonaro in the
southern state of hyugurangabusul just
as the trial to determine his political
future kicked off bolsonaro says he's a
victim and denies any wrongdoing
actually it's a political trial with the
lowest of intentions on the part of some
I'm not attacking the superior electoral
court but some of the arguments been
made are unbelievable in Brazilia a
panel of seven judges heard from the
prosecution in the defense before
beginning to rule on the case which will
be decided by a majority bolsonaro is
being charged with abusing his power as
president to undermine The credibility
of Brazil's October election three
months before he lost his bid for a
second term
at the center of the case is a meeting
he held with foreign ambassadors making
unfounded claims that Brazil's voting
system could be easily rigged and
casting doubts on its results
remarks to ambassadors from other
countries were broadcasted on public
television and social media allegedly
with the intent of attacking the
electoral process by spreading and I
quote this information about Brazil's
electronic voting system at the time of
the meeting in July of last year Brazil
was facing a polarized electoral
campaign and polls were showing
bolsonaro trailing behind his archrival
current president Louisiana
bolsonaro's lawyer says he's being
punished simply for expressing his
doubts about the electoral system and
that the punishment prosecutors are
asking for is unwarranted
if convicted bolsonaro would be banned
from running for public office until
2030. we are discussing the succession
on the presidential race uh we we will
decide the next president on 2026 and so
far bolsonaro was one of the main uh
pre-candidates and uh more likely one of
the the only ones that could defeat
president Lula if he decided to run for
re-election so the implications of this
trial is enormous on on Brazilian
Politics the trial will resume next week
on June 27th and a decision by the
judges could come soon afterwards before
the one month July recess Monica yanakev
al-jazeera Brasilia